[Music]
nine
hello there very good evening to you are
watching The Press preview of course
it's a first look at what's on the front
pages as they arrive here at the Sky
News Center time to see what's making
the headlines we're joined tonight by
the columnist Carol Malone and the
political innocent of the Liverpool Echo
Liam Thorpe now they both are thank you
so much for joining us we'll be uh with
us in just a few minutes time and
they're joining us until midnight
tonight let's start by seeing what's on
some of those front pages for you though
starting with the I newspaper it reports
tonight that NHS doctors are stranded in
the conflict in Sudan because they don't
have UK citizenship and they've refused
help being airlifted the guardian
tomorrow leads with a warning from the
Chief Inspector of constabulary that a
Scotland Yard could be failing to spot
serial killers because it's not properly
investigating unexpected deaths the
times tomorrow leads with the latest
Crackdown on gambling which is aimed at
saving young people from addiction the
mirror leads with a story about the
effects of the famine in East Africa
with the headline please help us
EI adio we've done the cup that is how
the Metro reports that train drivers are
to strike on the very day that two big
Manchester football clubs to send on
Wembley for the FA Cup Final on June 3rd
and in reaction to that the express asks
just how cynical can Rel unions be while
the male tomorrow labels the action as
vindictive the financial times leads
with news that Tory eurosceptors are
angry about a government plan to abandon
a review of all EU laws currently on the
UK statute book and the telegraph speaks
to baroness follower Benjamin about the
coronation and her role which she says
proves the king Embraces diversity
final one for you the star tomorrow
claims that scientists in Mexico have
found the mummified body of a goblin
quick reminder for you that by scanning
the QR code you'll see on screen during
the program you can check out the front
page of tomorrow's papers while you
watch with us well as I said earlier we
are joined Now by a Carol Malone and
Liam Thorpe Let's uh say hi to both of
them thanks so much for staying up late
on Thursday night to talk to us we do
appreciate it and we've got the front
pages ready for you waiting let's start
with the Metro why don't we EI adio
we've done the cup pretty good headline
well Liam what do you think start with
you first
um yeah so this is obviously the story
of of two new sets of of train strikes
that have been announced today uh one is
of the aslef Union which represents the
drivers who are in their own
long-running dispute with uh multiple
operators and that is going to affect
the FA Cup Final in June between
Manchester United and Manchester City
and then we have the continuing rmt
strike and which is going to affect
um the Eurovision song contest which is
of course being hosted where I currently
I'm in Liverpool so it's it's it's huge
disruption and you know this is
obviously what strikes are designed to
do these are two of the the biggest
events that the UK will host um in in
the coming months and obviously there's
a lot of a lot of frustration because
you'll have loads of fans going down
from from Manchester to London on June
the third and of course you'll have
loads and loads of people coming up to
Liverpool for the Eurovision song
contest throughout that weekend on that
final on the Saturday I think you know
look from from the Union's perspective
if they will have wanted to settled a
long time ago they don't will have not
wanted to do this you know you'll see
some other front pages that say that
they seem to that claim that they seem
to be enjoying this they will have
wanted this result and they are saying
that you know particularly in as less
case it was a derisary offer of four
percent when inflation is running at 10
and from the rmt's perspective they said
that
um the rail delivery Group which
represents the operators has effectively
torpedoed any kind of deal by Say by
including a clause that would mean that
they would be unable to strike or unable
to vote on strike him going forward so
kind of taking away their industrial
mandate does seem like there's some some
hijinks going on look I I'm a football
fan and I'm um obviously it's hugely
excited about Eurovision being here in
Liverpool and I want it to be a massive
success for this city but I also do
fundamentally believe in the right to
strike and if you are going to strike
you you have to make the biggest impact
and boy they're going to do that on
these two days I'd love to find out what
your readers think of it in just a few
minutes but let's bring Carol in now um
and it's not just the the Metro we've
got the Daily Express and also uh The
Daily Mail leading with this let's have
a look at the daily Express's headline
just how cynical canrell unions be I
mean it's obvious what their position is
what's yours Carol and where do you what
do you think general public is the
feeling about this
oh I think the general public will be
losing patients there but I thought it
was very funny how Liam who does
fundamentally agree with people's
righteous right but whose heart will be
breaking currently
about about the fact that the football
is going to be disrupted you did well
not to cry then it was good anyway and
you know
you know I'm with my paper and I'm with
I'm with the mail on this I think it's
vindictive and yes Liam says it strikes
are designed to cause a maximum effect
yes they are but you know what this is
hurting working people this is I'm sorry
the noise you've been here now is my dog
Murphy
and he won't shut up stop it
we're gonna have to meet Murphy at the
end of the pay-per-view I think but
carry on
because I think it's really really
vindictive and naughty and I think that
public sympathy is wearing thin now this
is hurting people on you know there's
not much fun for anybody at the moment
really there's not everyone's everyone's
struggling everyone's you know this cost
of living crisis money is tight and here
they are on the days where they could
they could do and see something that
would be fun and that will be uplifting
and it's going to be spoil for many
people especially actually European
Eurovision song contest a lot of
Ukrainian refugees will be making their
way there to see this this contest is
being held in their honor in this
country we're hosting it and this is
going to be a massive disappointment if
these people can't get to see their
country represented in this country it's
shocking and it is cynical and it is
vindictive and I really do think the
public are getting weary of this now and
Liam said before that a lot of these
unions want the strikes resolved oh
please come on these are the train
drivers who are earning 60 Grand a year
so four percent might be derisory to
someone on half of that but it sure is
heli when you're on 60 Grand a year and
you work a four day week they could have
solved this they're just being bloody
because they want to they want to mess
with the toys and I think that's why I
think it's shocking as well apart from
the fact is who is in working people and
and your readers Liam how do you think
they feel about this I mean they might
not care about not being able to watch
their the two big Manchester clubs
battle it out down in Wembley but what
about the Eurovision I mean it's going
to put Liverpool on on on the map isn't
it and if it's going to affect people
getting there are your readers patients
going to start running thin
and no I don't think so no you know
Liverpool has is As Cities go it
probably has one of the proudest
traditions of of industrial action and
and you know that that you will
regularly find people out on picket
lines and it's an important part of the
culture here in Liverpool there's no
doubt that it would have it will have an
impact on what is a a huge event for for
the city of Liverpool you know we're
extremely proud to be hosting Eurovision
on behalf of Ukraine
um and it's a massive moment for the
city but I think ingrained in in most
scousers is that fundamental right to
strike and as I said before it's it's
painful and and this is going to
directly affect us but these people have
been involved in this dispute for a long
time I've been in and spoken to many
many rail workers on picket Lions who
are really just unable to make ends meet
at the moment and uh
yeah
but obviously what about the the people
you know the guards the people on on the
trains earning a lot less than that as
well and they're really struggling and
as left you know I'm not good yeah but
the rmt is is also obviously on strike
as well they're not going to give up now
and they want to make the biggest impact
um it's it's difficult it's very it's
very very important you're talking about
your city being proud to host the
Eurovision song contest but this is
going to mess it up for your city do you
not care about that you know this this
was this is another chance to put
Liverpool on the map to put your proud
city on the map and it's going to be
messed up by these guys on 60 Grand a
year who don't need you I think if you
if you came Carol if you came here and
you spoke to most people they would say
that they fully backed people who are
fighting for a fair wage against Rising
inflation
and and if the government and the rail
delivery group wanted to settle this
they would they would have done a long
time ago they have drugged it out to the
union demands all the time how's that
going to work Leah does the government
came into every Union demand this
country is in massive trouble at the
moment because and if all the people get
the money is that they want inflation is
never going to go down we know that and
yeah
look like at the end of the day these
these people work hard every day they
are they are our Public Services if they
are absolutely essential which they are
proving now they are if they are
absolutely essential workers because
they need to get people to major events
on major days because the railways are
utterly essential to that then you have
to pay them what they believe they
deserve and these these Union people you
know the unions these you can go on
about the union Barons like you like to
do but at the end of the day ordinary
working people voted for this mandate
and they still have this mandate and
they're going to continue with it until
they believe that they're getting a fair
wage I'm gonna jump in because as
interesting as this is and it really is
we want to have a look at some more of
the front pages if you don't mind
because we're going to run out of time
um let's have a look at the eye front
page for you now the eye newspaper going
on a completely different story talking
about of course the situation in Sudan
and the evacuations that we've been
covering on Sky News the last few days
it leads with the story that NHS doctors
stranded in Sudan after
um the uh stranded in Sedona should say
after the UK refuses airlift it goes on
to say NHS Medics without UK citizenship
are set to be left behind after being
barred from the airlift the British
government has decided that opening up
cartoon evacuation flights to Health
Service doctors would be too complex in
the limited time frame left to complete
the operation safely no right to reply
it seems on that front page but Carol I
mean this sounds pretty outrageous what
do you think about this Carol it's I was
astonishing to him I can't believe it
presumably these NHS doctors are out
there helping with the crisis and and
ones who don't have a British passport
are being told no you can't come back if
if that is the case and they're out
there to help with this crisis it is
outrageous you know it's this is this is
shocking on every level we know that
some of the Brits have come back today
you know I think it's about 897 have
come back today but there are still
potentially thousands more Brits out
there and and you know this is this is
fast turning into a humanitarian crisis
you know we know that that that that
many people are making their way to the
points where they catch the evacuation
flies they're having to walk hundreds of
miles and there they're being robbed and
they're being attacked and they're
frightened for their life they're
frightened to being shot and you know
we've got troops on the ground to
provide security the airports but not
for those bids who are making their way
to the airport you know so so it is
shocking and you know we're hearing
reports now that the situation in
cartoon was really bad you know
hospitals where lots of people are being
admitted Brits as well uh you know
they're running out of medication that
the electricity is going off the heating
is going off and the food is running out
this is going to turn into something
terrible in the next few days and Brits
are going to be caught up in that and if
we have people out there working for the
NHS and trying to help they should be
brought back you know if we get our
diplomats out in time if we can get
foreign office people out in time we can
sure as hell get doctors out in time
then what do you make of this
yeah for once I'm in total agreement
with Carol on that one I think it's
absolutely scandalous you know these
people they may not have British
citizenship but they have the same
rights as a British national they are
they are they are out there they are
just unlucky enough to have been in
Sudan you know either working or
visiting and they are they are now you
know the government has said in a very
kind of casual response they will be
they will be able to make an exit
through other exit points well those
other exit points involve a 500 Mile
perilous journey to you know into Egypt
or to through the port this is about as
dangerous a journey as you could have in
the world right now with with obviously
the outbreak of fighting between the the
military and the militia there it's it's
a it's a shocking position for for an
NHS staff member to be in and and and
the government has been found wanting on
this you know other countries we've seen
like Germany who were much faster to
um to act on this they have they
completed their evacuations by Tuesday
we are still going we're still way
behind and now the government because
it's Scrabble is now having to make
these ridiculously difficult decisions
and ridiculously wrong decisions sorry
where which will leave NHS staff out in
Sudan fighting for their lives on their
own